Normally, this time of the year, the entire tech world is touching down in Las Vegas,...
...for a big week of news, strange gadgets and lots of walking around a giant show floor.
But this year, the pandemic means that CES' 2.9 million square feet of exhibition space...
...are being replaced by an all digital event.
Brands like LG and Procter & Gamble are creating virtual booths online...
...instead of the flashy physical exhibits we've seen in the past.
Panasonic is hosting a virtual concert by Cold War Kids...
...and instead of packed keynotes, all the big press conferences are streaming online.
Now, details are still under wraps...
...but we're expecting to see the launch of three new Galaxy S21 phones...
...with better cameras and maybe even an integrated S Pen like we've seen on the Note.
LG is launching a range of mini LED TVs known as QNED...
...and we're probably going to expect shiny new OLEDs from LG TV as well.
LG Display is also showing off a transparent OLED for commercial applications.
Samsung has also unveiled a range of new microLED TVs...
...including a 110-inch model with a 156,000-dollar price tag,...
...as well as new QLED models and an updated version of its Frame TV,...
...which is designed to look like an artwork on your wall.
Now, CES is normally a show for high-tech gadgets...
...but it's also a show for high-tech appliances.
Samsung is launching its new Bespoke refrigerator range...
...with a modular design available in pastel pink and blue,...
...and LG is upgrading its InstaView refrigerator...
...with a door that opens via voice command...
...and a water dispenser that sanitizes your water with UV light.